the jurogan experience how much
difference is it perspective-wise when
you're
when you're in space and you're looking
down on the earth
like that has got to be the ultimate
mindfuck it's
amazing so that this is what i'm trying
to do in life like
a couple books i've written some films
i've done um
seeing the earth i remember early in my
first flight it was like
okay i'm in outer space and my there's
my planet over there you know it was
this profound
thought that wow i'm not on the planet
anymore
and over over seven months in space
it never got old like it was always like
man earth is beautiful it is this
incredible
planet um and so there's so we could
talk for hours about this but
i think for me the biggest perspective
change was
um i'm less of a black and white person
now like
before i went into space i knew right
wrong and
a lot of when you're young you kind of
you're black and white as you get older
you get wiser and
seeing the planet seeing the planet it's
like yeah
the this thing's been around for a long
time and it's going to be around for a
long time so you probably don't need to
get as uptight about
you know the day-to-day stress of life
and
um it's uh it just kind of
put things in perspective like don't get
too excited about the kardashians or
whatever the latest political tweet was
or whatever um
like you know things are going to go on
for a long time and so that it helps
put that in perspective in a big way
it's interesting that
an actual physical perspective change
just being
just being in a different place where
you're looking down on it from a
different vantage point
yeah all the astronauts seem to say that
it has this profound shift
in how you think of earth and how you
think of humanity in general
yeah you know one of the interesting
things i've been traveling since i was a
kid i did some exchange
uh programs in finland and france and in
the air force i lived all around the
world
and whenever i would go to france or
korea or wherever it was like all right
i'm in korea
and then i get back to the states i'm
like all right i'm back back home in
america or whatever
and now when i travel and i've been
traveling a lot last couple years
i don't ever i always feel like i'm home
like it was weird
one time i landed in the middle east and
i remember thinking
i didn't think anything and that really
struck me because it used to always be
such a big deal wherever i landed
i kind of feel like i'm home no matter
where i'm at which is wow interesting
and that's from the space travel i i it
is yeah
wow yeah it it wasn't conscious i didn't
like
expect it or whatever i just realized
that hey i don't ever i don't ever feel
like i'm not at home
and my my crew mate samantha said
something really profound she said um
like you see earth and you could tell
it's going around the sun
like you can actually see the motion
sometimes if you're watching stars and
stuff
and it's like we're on the spaceship
together so we ought to be crewmates and
not just passengers
yeah like we all ought to kind of take
care of
the planet and ourselves each other and
stuff do you find that most of the
or many of the astronauts share this
similar
perspective shift that once you go up
you do realize
the how weird it is that there are these
tribal differences between us
yeah you're like what the hell are we
doing i got a story about that but
to be honest we're probably not the best
um
communicators of emotion you know like
you know we're not
necessarily all touchy feely people but
some of my close friends that we talk
about this
there's a very there's a very similar
perspective of you know we're all here
on the
on the planet together i was on my first
flight on the shuttle and it was the
fifth
i remember it was the fifth night there
and i looked out we were going over the
mediterranean at night
and you could see there's this like
u-shape where there's egypt in the nile
there's israel and syria and lebanon
right there and there's turkey and
greece and it's this little area
and israel is this little thing that's
surrounded by jordan and lebanon you
know they're all like right there
and i remember thinking like guys what's
the problem man you're
you're you're literally living together
on a postage stamp on this big planet
yeah and it wasn't anything about israel
or the middle east specifically it was
more like
why can we not get along just human down
here yeah and the crazy thing is
if you ask most people their their
position is
they'll never be peace in the middle
east so
which is crazy one of the things after
my flight so
we would they'd send us to congress and
we talked to congressmen and senators
and i got to talk at the white house
a couple years ago at the national space
council and my message to them is always
the same it's always
you know for a space program it's not
about the rocket science it's about the
political science
like we got to figure out politics to
get things working well
and whenever i go to the american
congress they're always like you're
right it's exactly right if it wasn't
for those other [ __ ] on the other
side we could get this right
republicans democrats all said that they
all totally agreed with me and it was
always the other guy's fault
there's a there's a there's definitely a
problem that is going to be tough to
overcome how much benefit would there be
in getting those people in space
yeah you know people talk about that if
only that leaders could go into space
and
i think for some of them it would make
an impact and some of them they wouldn't
care
i mean they're sick well the goal of
politics and power is just to keep
yourself in power and get more stuff for
yourself and
you know throughout human history it's
not normally you know
altruistic democracies the way we run
ourselves um
so which that we need to move in that
direction because that's the way life
gets better
but um i think some it would benefit and
some it wouldn't
the thing is like no one really wants
the job that is
balanced and healthy and intelligent and
has a good perspective for
perspective for humanity yeah the people
that want the job they want to be the
king poo ba
they mean they want to be the dog yeah
he's just a weird
kind of person that wants that job in
the first place it's uh
people are like why don't you run for
office and and i always say well do you
have a give me a fork you have a fork
because i want to stick that in my
because that would be more fun than
you know you try and do something nice
and you're just getting non-stop hate
mail and
yeah it's a rough girlfriend's from high
school
testifying before congress this thing
that happened 30 years ago
yeah exactly it's um it's fascinating to
me
how many of the astronauts do have this
incredibly profound experience again
just from
the physical act of being above earth
looking down on it where this
perspective shift
just kind of changes your your overall
thoughts about being in space being
a part of humanity on this organic
spaceship
in the universe rather than being like
locked down in chicago right there's
clouds above you so i don't even think
about space
dude stuck in traffic on your way to
work every day same grind every you get
stuck
in this narrow-minded perspective almost
every astronaut who discusses this
says that it was a profound
life-changing moment to look at earth
from above
yeah it was and you know i can like
close my eye if i'm in one of those
shitty situations you just close your
eyes and it's like
right now the sun is rising somewhere
that's the most beautiful thing you
can't imagine it
you know i took a lot of pictures i did
movies but unless you see it with your
eyes you know you can't imagine how
awesome it is so that takes the edge off
the traffic you're having to wait on and
um it does help but the the thing is
like
taking that experience and sharing it
with as many people as possible
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience